hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast advancements in WBC
differential technology presented by
John Wright scientific affairs manager
hematology Abba Diagnostics I'm
Christina Joel elaborate and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminars brought
to you by lab ropes and sponsored by
Abbott Diagnostics now before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click the send button will
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation if
you have any trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right of your
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the answer
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit
now I'd like to introduce our presenter
mr. Don Wright Don Wright is a global
scientific affairs manager for Abbott
Diagnostics hematology Don has worked in
clinical laboratory services and the
commercial hematology industry for the
entirety of his career in his current
role Don provides scientific support for
healthcare professionals and serves as a
scientific resource to various functions
including R&D business development
global strategic operations and other
departments for more detailed biography
on Don Wright please click on his
biography tab at the top of this page I
would now like to turn the presentation
over to mr. John Wright mr. Wright you
may begin your presentation
traduction and i would like to welcome
you to today's webinar advancements in
WBC differential technology
the speaker program is sponsored by and
on behalf of avid Diagnostics
content of this presentation is
consistent with all applicable FDA
requirements
technological developments and automated
hematology analyzers continue to
transform the hematology laboratory
each new generation collects more
information about properties of blood
cells and the previous generation
hematology analyzers are available from
multiple manufacturers each uses
different combination of detection
methods
we'll cover the following objectives
first I will share with you brief review
of key milestones in the history of
automation related to the WBC and
differential counts next an overview of
methodologies used on automated WBC and
differential cell counting analyzers and
how those methods are applied in
contemporary hematology analyzers
also discuss the impact on the
laboratory in performing the manual
differential and the improvements made
to minimize interfering substances that
are identification of abnormal cells and
flagging
and lastly I will discuss some key
trends in automated differential
analysis
so I'd like to share with you brief
history of key automated systems that
contributed to the development of
automated WBC and differential analysis
systems
prior to the 50s WBC counts were usually
performed manually using the
hemocytometer in the 100 cell
microscopic differential count was
performed using several variants of the
Romanovs key stains like right Ginza may
Grenville key milestones with the award
of a patent to Wallace Coulter for using
electronic method for counting particles
truly thereafter he introduced the first
viable electronics all kind of the ultra
Model A
production of the transistors this led
to later models of cell counters model
FM and model s the Model S was the first
automated analyzer providing a seven
parameter CBC result replacing manga
evolutions and counts reduced the
turnaround time the one minute on what
was usually taking a lie between 15
minutes in the early seventies technicon
instruments introduced the Humalog d5
part differential analyzer based on side
of chemistry staining the WBC
subpopulations while analyzing them with
a continuous flow optical measurement
system
approaches were taken by multiple
manufacturers that produce three funds
and six-part differential results along
the way as a need to reduce some number
of annual differentials continue to
drive the development of the automated
differential improvements were being
made to develop computer-based automated
discs Digital morphology analyzers
these systems use primitive software to
characterize WBC images from write
stained smears provide an estimate of
each cell classification providing
images - for the technologists confirmed
by computer screen review the geometric
data Hema track model 591 such early
system in the 80s six-part differential
was fully incorporated in a benchtop CCC
no answer from Technic on which also
incorporated a laser for light scatter
detection on that system the abbot's
Aldean 4000 was introduced in 1996 with
capability for automated enumeration of
n RBC automated reticulocyte accounts
and later introduced automated
monoclonal antibody assets for CD 61 in
plate account as well as one per site
subset testing
the past 20 years there's been a
continuous iterations of technological
improvements the new methods providing
even more reliable means of reporting
automated differentials
you
so the goal of automated WBC
anshel method development is to design
the detection technologies for the
purpose of improving the accuracy in
reportable automated nettabi
subpopulations resulting ultimately in
fewer manual differentials
over the many generations of modern
automated hematology analyzers a variety
of technologies and method combinations
have been developed with each new
generation of analyzer in this slide
methodologies represent the technologies
utilized in cell counting and
applications are how these technologies
have put together in combination to
produce the WBC and differential
I will now review several commonly use
technologies used in automated WBC
differential analysis
beginning with impedance technology RF
conductivity optical light scatter
butter chemistry the use of fluorescence
detection after review of the methods
ever provided overview how these
technologies are incorporated in the
multi or single channel applications
the impedance method is based on the
measurement of changes in DC electric
electrical current which are produced by
a cell suspended an electrolyte solution
as a passes through a very small
aperture of known dimensions positive
and negative electrode is submerged on
either side of the aperture to create an
electrical pathway as each cell passes
through the aperture the change in the
resistance between the electrodes is
produced because blood cells are poor
conductors of electricity this change
for this is a measurable electrical
pulse which can then be used to estimate
number and size of the particles that
traverse the aperture
challenge for this method in the early
years was managing coincident events due
to the closeness of cells as they pass
through the aperture and recirculation
of cells around the detection area of
the aperture and being recounted
impedance technology continue to evolve
with changes to the reagent systems that
for use eventually delivering a three
part WBC differential in this slide
we're looking at a blood sample treated
with a licen reagent to lyse RBC's and
permeable eyes the white blood cell
membrane causing the membrane to
collapse around the nuclear and
cytoplasm components of the cell delbert
white cells can then be separated using
impedance into three general groups
based on the Southside from smallest to
largest lymphocytes mid-range cells and
granulocytes
normal cells may appear as transitional
populations that overlap between normal
populations such as n RBC's play the
clumps giant planets or on those red
cells to name a few
an abnormal cells are detected these
need to be resolved with an alternate
method such as a microscopic slide
review or 100 cell menu differential
another key patent issued
70 was the discovery of a high-frequency
signal using alternating current which
was defined as radio frequency opacity
or conductivity
frequency alternating current signal
could demonstrate different properties
of the WBC subpopulations
measurement of wbcs as a pasty resulted
in response changes due to nuclear
composition cytoplasmic density and
other internal structures of the white
blood cell in this instance of
electrical detection the WBC cell law
acts as a conductor of AC current the
signal changes are not limited to event
and time the RF measurements still used
in some hematology systems to this day
okay so one of the difficulties
associated with cell measurements as we
saw with the impedance transducer it's
really controlling the WBC's and other
cells from irregular recirculation in
and around detection zones in this tin
case of the impedance the aperture this
interference of duplication of signals
by the same cell required correction and
it was found that they could correct
so for impedances could resolve in
examining resolving pulses and find
false editing circuitry try to evolve
past the problems that the cells created
the neighbor detected more than what
however for optical detection a new
approach was needed to be developed
in a flow cytometry the self suspension
is actually pumped in the specimen
container through a sample to them to a
special flow chamber called a flow cell
with a small opening at the tip the
suspension is then injected into a
stream of fast-moving cell-free liquid
called the sheath floor
this is actually called laminar flow and
kind of works in the same context is
what laminar flow hood before two
liquids travel different rates of speed
they do not nor mingle
that's the what's called the laminar
flow special geometry of the flow cell
and flow rate of the sheet fluid cells
and it puts these cells actually in a
single-file line so if you see the
diagram or animation the right you can
see the cells intersecting a laser path
in a single-file line cells are actually
following the lease point of resistance
and since there are two converging
speeds they look for that easier pathway
that's why they then line themselves up
in single file so this whole process
that you see right here this is called
hydrodynamic focusing and all systems
that incorporate any type of profitable
subsystem for detection methods uses
some form of hydrogen I'm focusing the
hydrodynamic focusing is really not
limited to optical light scatter
measurements it's often incorporated
into impedance technologies as well to
further improve the accuracy of that
measurement so in this figure as you can
see the cells and sample stream that
they pass through creates that single
linear flow of cells one at a time
this animation actually demonstrates use
of hydrodynamic folk the theme and the
principles of optical light scatter
detection the focus flow stream of
diluted white blood cells are injected
into the flow cells we described by
hydrodynamic focusing and enter the cell
laser intercept area to concede by the
gred beam those cells intersect that
the cells scatter the light of different
angles actually they scatter light in
360 degrees but yet we're only
interested in certain angles of light
scatter the shields information about
the cell size internal structure
granularity and the even surface
morphology the optical signals the cells
generate are detected and kind of
converted to electrical impulse which
are then stored and analyzed by the
computer system after the analysis once
the final event is recorded this data is
then evaluated by an algorithm and all
angles of light scatter per event are
classified by their common
characteristics abnormal cells are
present flagging of those populations
are indicated and further follow-up is
required obviously again going back to
the manual differential
those are usually more than two
different scatter detectors
each detection signal can be graphically
represented in the form of thoughts on a
scatter plot as seen on the right hand
side the dots are plotted at a point
determined by the intersection of the
channel information designated on the X
and y axis for example the cell falls in
channel 50 on the x-axis and channel 50
on the wire is plotted at the
intersecting point of the two channel so
the scatter information may be plotted
in various combinations to yield
different information about the sample
we may have multiple scatter plots that
you could review looking for abnormal
events if the concentration of the cells
are too high where the stream speeds are
not optimized there can be a detection
of doublet or longer irregular signal
that could represent two cells in close
proximity very similar to what we saw in
impedance passing at the same time
therefore it's important that both the
dilution injection speeds are optimized
and that's when again the designs of the
new systems are our varam are set to do
okay I'd like to now transition over and
discuss how contemporary hematology
analyzers use various technologies and
methods to determine the five part or
greater DIF automated differential so
let's consider two primary approaches
the first we will call kind of a
multi-channel system multi-channel
approach makes use of two or more
discreet detection systems to quantitate
the reportable WBC and differential so
we are actually making two separate
solutions and analyzing them in separate
areas of the system for example
neutrophils eosinophils monocytes and
lymphocytes may be determined and
reported from one method or technology
and basophils and n RBC's reported from
a second method or technology and WBC's
perhaps by a third method for technology
this approach uses the detection
strength of one technology to kind of
overcome the limitation of another
technology ultimately we're trying to
improve the overall detection rate and
apply the appropriate flagging to make
sure we have an accurate result the
second approach we'll talk about is
called skittle channel system the single
channel system makes use of discreet
detection system to quantitate the
reportable WBC and differential in the
single channel approach only one
dilution provides all reportable results
and the detection system may use
multiple light scattering angles
multiple scattering angles of light
scanner with additional WBC staining
perhaps to improve the detection
sensitivity and minimize potential of
interference substance
okay here's example one of a
contemporary multi-channel analyzer
detection system
I will not recognize any of the
manufacturers in this approach but I
think most of you may you have this type
of technology will recognize it and this
instance you see the upper-left
histogram indicates the WBC is
determined by impedance measurement the
lower-left scatter product uses an
interval angle one light scatter and
volume to identify neutrophils
lymphocytes monocyte eosinophils and
basophils the lower-right scatter plot
uses opacity or radio frequency and
volume to complimentary identified
basophils even though they were seen in
the scatter plot to the left there
further verified with a scatter plot on
the right in additional combinations of
light scatters you can see on the upper
right scatter plot impedance on RF I'm
sorry of optical light loss to identify
NR becs
from wbcs that's resolving the WBC in
the five-part death and RBC so in this
instance you actually see six discrete
nucleated cell
dish accommodations of light scanner
used whether it be impedance light
scatter RF provides additional
information for detection of interfering
substances and of course flagging of
potentially abnormal cell types
okay this is example number two also
from a
temporary multi-channel analyzer this
system uses a side of chemical staining
method for the enzyme paroxetine found
in the granules of some white board
though the top plate you see up there at
the very top shows two peroxidase
negative cells at the upper left and
upper right of that image along with two
different proxies positive staining
cells at different levels of proxeny
concentrations on the bottom left and
bottom right the lower left scatter plot
displays the WBC cells proxy staining
activity on the x-axis and the relative
cell size and the y-axis and identifies
neutrophils lymphocytes monocytes
eosinophils and a classification it's
really not close by which is a large
proxies negative cell along with a
secondary total white count from this
channel as well so this pollution does
bring a lot of information the
lower-right scatter plot indicates
interval angle one right scatter on the
x axis and cell size from the y axis to
identify basophils along with the
primary WBC count and additional
information for interference detection
and flagging
but a chemistry was used in this
instance as well in the case where
actually staining not stainless cells
but we're doing selective lysine that
may be deemed as another terminology for
better chemical effect the basophils are
located above if you notice the other
light scattering event because they are
intact but cell membrane the lower
clusters are represented with WC nuclei
only are evaluated based on their
respective cell from within dense
and then it's example number three
contemporary multi-channel analyzer
detection system this system uses a
floor cone by standing up for
fluorescent labeling of WBC nucleic
acids proteins in the cytoplasmic
organelles and two angles of light Scott
the left scatterplot if you notice
indicates fluorescence activity on the
y-axis and lights get our angle 1 on the
X act to identify combined neutrophils
basophils population together
lymphocytes monocytes eosinophils
immature granulocytes along with
information on n RBC's and abnormal cell
the right scatter plot indicates flight
scatter angle 2 on the y axis and the
soul fluorescence on the x axis to
further identify basophils and n RBC's
and the WBC count along with additional
information for interferences detection
and fights
okay so now let's review a single
challenge system remember the single
channel approach makes use of one
discrete detection system to quantitate
the reportable WBC and differential one
dilution is used to provide all
reportable results in the WBC count
which would include neutrophils immature
granule sites
istana fills basophils lymphocytes
monocytes and RBC's an additional
information for the detection of
interferences and flagging of abnormal
cells when present
as we touch upon fluorescence
the multi-channel example this example
of a single Channel 4's applause item
Ettrick technology simultaneously
measures and analyzes multiple physical
characteristics of single cells as they
flow in a fluid strain through a beam of
light in this case a laser cell your
event property's measured include
multiple angles of light scatter as I
said not just to multiple which helps
determine the cell sine granularity
kernel complexity lobule arity
fluorescence intensity from the staining
of nucleic acids and nucleic cell these
characteristics are determined using an
optical to electronic conversion system
that records how the cells scattered
incident light and emits fluorescence
look at the upper-left image at low
resolution these are what the stained
nucleated cells look like the
upper-right image is a high-resolution
image of the categorized fluorescent
positive nucleic cells cellular events
and you can see clearly something that
looks very similar to when we look at a
microscopic evaluation of a racing smear
in this case obviously we're seeing one
color of fluorescence
the lower left image and lower right
image our scatterplot result combining
light scatter and fluorescence detection
identifying the self listed in the
bottom image in the center so from this
one single dilution we can manifest
complete six bars if actually seven if
you're including n RBC
okay this animation demonstrates the
processing of nucleated cells using a
single channel multi angle laser light
scatter and collection of fluorescence
emitted from the same cells
during this process the diluted cells
are rapidly injected
through the analyzers optical flow cells
we previously talked about in addition
the polarized light and red fluorescence
data is accumulated on up to 20,000
event as they pass through
the optical and fluorescence data the
unclassified cells is you see
accumulating on the right-hand side of
the graphic form the records the five
pieces of optical and fluorescence data
that we will use to classify those cell
these broadly equate to sell your SCI
complex the globular granularity in DNA
staining once the data is collected
20,000 events the software algorithms
take over and begin classifying cellular
event
nucleated red blood cells of the first
classified using this approach you can
see looking at their fluorescent
characteristics how they stand out in
all the events that are in the DNA
column that has that particular value
plus five are classified as an RBC
the remaining leukocytes are then
separate into modern nuclear power more
for nuclear events and are separated
using 90 degrees versus 90 degree
depolarized
to identify neutrophils from eosinophils
the remaining lymphocytes monocytes and
base Phil are separated and identified
using their size and complexity
characteristic
the data numbers that you see in the
center are the signatures the optical
signatures and fluorescence signatures
of each of the events which are later
classified as the salts indicated on the
on the grid
once the data is
and completed in the cellular events are
then color-coded to make it easy for the
operator to visualized cells and in this
three-dimensional representation of the
data it highlights that this is truly a
multi angle multi-dimensional analysis
completing the five part differential
so our as we've just described one of
the methodologies and the applications
of those methods we've come quite a long
way the advancement of being able to
resolve not only accurate white blood
cell counts but also the five-part or
six-part bus
differential we have actually seen
review rates of manual differentials
dropped dramatically over this period of
time however we have to ask ourselves at
times we go to laboratories this enough
information are they satisfied with this
and I think you ask yourself that
question
the answer is always no it's not the
reason for that is to this date labor
shortages continue to challenge the
laboratory especially testing continues
to increase as liver not where
populations are growing older and the
cliche the laboratory still must do more
with less continues to be discussed
always in the c-suite however
laboratories continue to report the
manual reviews and differentials are
still one of the most important criteria
when choosing a new hematology analyzer
and they see the time-consuming and
labor-intensive manual diff the primary
impediment and further de streamlining
their much needed labor sake
the need for manual reviews and
differentials based on many reasons this
is a study that was performed and
published by the CA T in 2006 called the
Q probe study and it looked at a number
of laboratories you can see I think the
numbers 263 institutions and over 95,000
differentials and they look to see what
actually it's the reason why we're doing
manual give me for the manual reviews
and differentials so based on many
reasons including lack of results
flagged results and the force
interferences so the reasons for reflex
manual smear reviews types reviews
performed assessment whether new
information we've learned from the
reviews is reported in the study as well
and to no surprise the WBC flag and or
presence of an immature self line
accounted for over 62 percent of samples
requiring further review this study is
nearly 12 years old number reviews may
have improved a little bit with the
advent of new technology but trust me
it's still a very large and considerable
number of reviews that remain to this
day due to these same reasons it's
interesting also to note that the manual
differential represented 60 the 40% edge
over the manual scam the appears that
people have a tendency because the
improvement of technology has maybe
reduce the instance of scanning but
because it cannot resolve the abnormal
pathologies increase the number of
manual discs compared to just trying to
do a scan
so
laboratories physicians and patients
face consequences a flag results are
reported without smear reviews we know
that interference associate with WBC and
differential now this has not been
eliminated in spite of all the
advancements that we've made in the
detection technologies used by new
generations of heme system the need to
visually visually review a flag remains
to be a very important step in the
verification validation of reportable
results this is a list of WBC
interferences that remain numerous and
laboratories SOPs are designed to
capture these when the analyzer flags or
indicates is a problem with example this
was a study that was done or actually a
publication that was done back in 2007
but we're still struggling with some of
the technologies on the market to
overcome some of these interferences
some of these interferences will never
be resolved because they are either pre
lennick pre analytical problems that may
have occurred in collection of the blood
sample or could be a condition that
would create problems such as high
lipids or even with clomp limit
so really instrument methods research
and development that we continuously are
trying to make strides and minimize the
impact the recent appearances and
surprisingly some of these have been
resolved but many of them are still
unresolvable
flagging efficiency of the automated
hematology white count and differential
technology becomes an important
contribution in increasing the
productivity by accurately decreasing
the review rates in other words when
developing new technologies many
cellular characteristics must be
factored in to try to understand and
identify especially the immature cell
types you can see the WBC black last
flagging on the left hand side the
variation in blasts is great high degree
of shapes and sizes and so therefore
with that there needs to be a variety of
strategies necessary to use our
detection systems to help find these
types of immature cells so laboratory
must also set their own flagging
response criteria as well International
Council for Standardization of
hematology published initial guidelines
with each laboratory should review and
adjust their protocols to the respective
patient population with respect to
flagging conditions
reduction in false positives and
minimize number of false negatives have
continued to improve with every
iteration of next generation system
however there's still a great deal of
room for improvement with the
improvements in laboratory information
systems though many rules may be applied
to coincide with the automated systems
of our flagging efficiency so we are
making progress unfortunately we're not
eliminating these altogether
so let's explore some of the future
trends of automated differential
analysis
we've talked about
several the current methodologies and
methodologies and associated
applications listed here but let's take
a closer look at potential developments
that may impact the next generation of
Hematology system
can we say will it be a new or improved
flora chrome development possible
improvements in reagent systems could be
a new detection system using advanced
optics or other technologies yet the
migrate to the hematology analyzer
platform it could be all votes could it
be additional light scatter intervals or
harnessing the advancements of
artificial intelligence with the use of
learning algorithm that catalog abnormal
cell types and remembers a respected
technological signatures that can later
teach the analyzer how to find the
abnormal cell
all of these are possible
this is also one development that could
be have a huge impact in the further
research of automated system and one
that is often not thought about that has
been brought to our attention by again
the ICS H their National Committee and
standards and hematology your financial
council standards in hematology and that
is design design you method for and
replacing the current reference method
for WBC differential that is totally
dependent on expert microscopy and the
statistical limiting 400 cell annual
differential the ICS H has indicated the
need for new reference method with a
leukocyte differential count and the Poe
Capote approach is to investigate flow
cytometry candidate methods using
multiple monoclonal antibody I can
recall many years ago maybe even 30
years ago was believed that this would
actually be the WBC differential the
future unfortunately the cost was
prohibitive in the aspect of the cost of
monoclonal antibody testing was realized
and the use of those technologies was
limited to special testing for advanced
disease detection and identification
installers today however if we had a
reference set of monoclonal antibody
methods that could be developed this
would provide manufacturers and
researchers the reproduce will confirm
ground truth cell classification for
improving their respective technologies
and subsequent algorithm development one
of the most frustrating applications
today is when we try to compare even
manual discs 200 so manual discs from
one observer to a second observer or
even to an arbitrator and oftentimes
when pathology is present they don't
match up so that inhibits our
opportunities to actually use our
learning algorithms to effectively
identify those cell types
so this would be and have a big impact
also perhaps as I mentioned previously
we could add additional light scatter
and improve the WBC differential
if a new reference method using my own
alibis for truth within mutes the
exploration refined characterization
cells and white scatter could be
improved using such approaches of
supervised learning technologies not
exactly a neural network dissolve in
random information but actual human
expert supervised learning technology
this would allow a reference ground
truth database to to this be established
and then to train the learning algorithm
by a network of information and big data
to understand exactly that this is going
to resolve this type of specific
abnormal cell type without that ground
truth database and very difficult to
push beyond where we are right now with
some of the advances of optical light
scatter and or other method
and of course I think we're all getting
used to the fact that digital morphology
is become part of our automated
experience but the WBC differential
advancements in digital morphology from
a cell locator to a diagnostic portable
someday could be a reality as you know
right now many of us use some sort of
digital morphology to help resolve and
do the differential and save time so it
becomes more of a cell locator and the
technologist will be called over to
actually look at and review the cells
that the digital morphology system has
identified but if you think about right
now as per Moore's law which really
isn't a law but States basically the CPU
processing power doubles about every two
to two-and-a-half years high resolution
digital morphology currently contains
lots of big data and it needs improve
processing power so it could be possible
that improvements in processing speed
using artificial intelligence and
advanced machine learning algorithms
could someday provide the human the
machine compatible WBC image in such
numbers that the cell locator could
actually report the results will over no
laboratory review so is that possible my
belief right now is this has to be one
of the leading trends in the advancement
of more reportable automated
differentials
so in summary the advancements in W
see an automated differential testing is
evolved over the past 60 years to the
point that normal WBC and discs are
largely reported without human
intervention to this day the average
review rates could range from 50% in
your large oncology hospital settings
the may be as few is less than 10% in
some of the hospitals I have more of a
normal patient population it remains a
significant number of manual
differentials however that need to
laboratory review the advancements and
methodologies and increasing processor
speeds may further improve our
automation to the point where only a
handful of manual reviews would be
necessary in the business of
laboratories
all right I'd like the
everyone for attending today and we're
going to answer some questions as they
come up thank you
thank you John for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the answer question
box located on the far left of your
screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for okay done
our first question is now we heard about
single and multi-channel approaches to
delivering the WBC differential is there
a particular advantage you would think
one approach has over the other thanks
Christy for the question the Gertz the
multi-channel approaches there were very
well thought-out systems it's kind of
interesting to note over the development
of technologies when systems going to
come together from manufacturer
standpoint often limiting because there
has been some you know progress made
with means etc that that particular
manufacturer may not be able to use so
what would has occurred is you had this
approach were creatively they've
developed the methods and technologies
to work around patents in some cases and
when you look at a multi-channel
approach you are using multiple
solutions as well generally speaking
your reagent you see two reagents needed
to accommodate those technologies is
also multiple types of sets the reagent
systems so with respect to that you have
two delusions possibly maybe more
multiple reagents to support those
solutions and those methods in the end
result I'm sure it's a good result but
there can be again if one particular
method is is problematic you know you
have the higher incident perhaps maybe
of a problem where I have to repeatedly
work them manual different completed
single channels
some probably will save the laboratory
from a reagent standpoint they're
usually minimal reagents it's a single
dilution it also accommodates higher
throughput at times because you're just
going through in a single pass approach
and typically the simple reagent system
will make this the system overall a
little less complex so there may be some
advantages with the single channel
approach over the multi but again I
think the end result with the urge to
your reportable differentials will be
fairly similar
thank you John our next question comes
in from Vicki she would like to know is
there an EBT a effect on the accurate
determination of individual WBC
identification for example should you
wait a specific period of time prior to
running a specimen that's good question
and it's very dependent on your
technology and system that you're using
as generations a system have come along
there's there's less need to wait again
I would refer to the manufacturers
operator's manual but they're early on
and as some of the impedance methods
especially a three differential
technology methods evolve there appeared
that there was some impact on the
stabilization period that EDTA has on
the white blood cells within that first
15 to 20 minutes and most of time though
from the point of where the step was
drawn by the time to get to the
laboratory that carried would when he
laps and there was no real issues with
performing that example but for the most
part the modern systems contemporary
systems are out there you see little if
not no effect of EDTA on on the on the
white count or the subpopulations that
it's time to identify
now dawn would it be possible to include
a live dead stain in the future yes
there's actually a system that's on the
market at this point that does use the
staining process that actually does
determine and and kind of a viability of
the white blood cells repeating my
tightest the actual stain that it uses
and that's been pretty well established
as a good staying for viability
detection other methods as they evolved
also provide similar cell wall
permeabilization rates and
identification of live or dead cells and
may report them and the viability
fraction to the operator that could then
use that information interment the
samples age sample or not before there's
other problems that impacting that
results that them
now John why is the throughput of a
hematologist not getting to higher
levels while volume of testing continues
to rise they seem to be stuck at about
you know around 100 cdc's per hour
that's a good question I think there are
some limitations when using the kind of
when you're doing a dilution you do have
to have some interaction time with your
particular reagent system with your
method or application and then you
actually have to have counting time so
once that sample has been diluted has to
wait for a few seconds and then inject
it into your detection system so the
complexities of delivering all the
information of the systems delivered
today you know is somewhat predicated
based on you know incubation times
perhaps or just the number of samples
going through and it's the generally
speaking you know about every 30 seconds
you know you have to hold a sample
before you can actually analyze it
John is there a system that is better
for age samples
um every manufacturer has guidelines I
think in their operator's manual which
discusses their ability to to work with
age samples and it's important to look
at those studies those are published
studies and again I think you can draw
your conclusions on how one method or
another would work with regards to
running all age samples there's no doubt
as EDTA
samples age the other white blood cells
do change their cell membranes begin to
be brown eyes and there are both
internal as well as external differences
from fresh sample to an aged sample with
that in mind your counts are going to be
okay I think where you will see any
impact may be somewhat unflagging and
with respect to one system or other
having flagging some systems do actually
take into consideration some of the
flagging that could be associated with
non-viable events and that's if they're
detecting viability where some systems
don't have that capability but just you
know ask the manufacturers if they
accounted for that
Thank You Don now the bulk of technology
innovations they seem to you know pin in
the 1970s 1980s why has there been a
slowdown in their recent years
oh well you know I don't know if there's
actually been a slowdown per se have we
seen you know huge changes like we did
you know as the pursue to to report the
five part or six part differential you
know in that period of time it was a you
know I would say maybe the automated
period of discovery were you know people
say hey I have a method I have an
application that I can determine the
other subpopulations and the challenge
went out but when to get into the rare
event the situation of abnormal and
pathology pathological cells it becomes
quite difficult to really try to
maintain throughput and maintain methods
without trying to find something else
unique that would actually identify
those particular abnormals so you know I
think we're just entering a new age a
new age of advanced processing speed I
think maybe a new age of alternate
approaches to resolving abnormals and
interferences so yes yeah we've seen
those improvements over the past 20
years as I mentioned in presentation I
think we're on the verge of seeing some
greater advancements based on harnessing
just the artificial intelligence and
processing powers that are now brought
to our our systems and been able to look
at new algorithms and approaches to that
ready for a new stage of development
excellent Thank You Don we have times
with you more questions now looking at
their limitations in providing
differential results is there still a
place for the impedance technology in
today's laboratory
oh absolutely I think that you know
depending on your complexity of your
laboratory that types of patients that
you are processing certainly impedance
those provide you know a robust counting
approach with not only counting the
cells but even in their approach of
doing the three part differential um I
don't find those becoming obsolete
in any year you know anytime soon unless
there's another quicker approach then
more dry approach to doing the count as
opposed to perhaps doing the the
dilution proach
do you see team ecology testing moving
to POC approach like many others I think
it's already there if you take a look at
some of the point-of-care testing
systems you'll have some sort of
hematology values there um again it's
going to be limited information and for
quick screening I think for immediate
understanding of the general health and
that's with obviously the CBC provides
in particularly the Anka parameter such
as hemoglobin to assure that we are
dealing with something that we can test
for anemia white counts and and those
populations are a little bit more
challenging again some have very small
analyzers that can perform those again
for quick screening that I think that's
still going to be a need for that in the
point-of-care testing for sure
Thank You Don and thank you for your
important research do you have any final
comments for our audience
well again I appreciate everyone
attending today's webinar and certainly
I think as we look forward in the area
of automated hematology there's a lot
ahead of us and I think a lot to
discover yet someday I think they will
happen very very quickly as far as
reportable bbc's and I think we will
eventually get to the point where we
will look back and say how why did it
take so long to get to this point as we
have previously when you look at the
history of hematology so again
appreciate it and thank you very much
thank you again Don now before we go I
would like to thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration we would like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor Abbott Diagnostics
for underwriting today's educational
webcast this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through September 2018 lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues to admit who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye